Have you gone over recent court memes? Um, no. I don't know if
there's any point in going over any of this stuff anymore. They
um I I'm hoping I hope there are sanctions for this case when
this is over. Uh they just they don't understand the like rules
of civil procedure and they don't understand um I guess anything
having to do with I I don't I truly I can't explain it. I'm not
sure. Um they keep they keep trying to cite these like local
rules for how they want to file things under seal like local
rule 5.4 B1. If you read these like the local rules or if you
know anything about civil procedure you you can't file stuff
under seal and keep it from the defense. You just can't do that.
I don't know why they keep trying to make this argument that
they can like you can't do this. You're not allowed to do this.
Defendant's opposition completely ignores the substantive basis
for the motion. one good cause for sealing the identities is
established since the declarations contain sensitive and private
intimate details but you yourself said that the details are there
you just don't have the names so which part matters like you
have I have to know who a witness is I have to know who uh somebody
who's purporting to support the plaintiff is I have to know this
I have a right to know this and two public disclosure of the
identities of these witnesses would expose the witnesses to harassment
embarrassment possible harm and retaliation if this is true you've
undermined your own you've undermined your own motion by publicly
releasing the screen name of at least one of the people involved
which allows people to identify who she is and that's already
happened but their own filings are sloppy. Um so they've already
undermined this and also if you want to publicly file something
under seal meaning to keep it from the public fine but you still
have to make that available to us. None of the rules allow you
to file something that the defense doesn't know who the person
is. Well, there might be I'm not going to say none of the rules,
but there might be some like really exceptional rule. Like I
know with child cases, I think there are really special rules
that can apply to accusers or victims to keep their stuff sealed.
Um, but like outside of like an extraordinary case like that,
you just can't do that.
Um, they also keep bringing up just like random stuff. Defendant
has publicly threatened, physical harm to individuals have spoken
out against him and in support of plaintiff for Jessica and Queman
and Lav and Mr. Girl. These people aren't part of this case.
These people are not involved in this complaint. I don't know
why they keep bringing these names up. These people aren't mentioned
as witnesses. These people aren't mentioned as parties to the
complaint. They're not part of this. So, I don't know why they
keep blog posting in these motions.
Um, they try to bring up this again. They undermine themselves.
They say that um so they say that I used her name for instance
after they filed the um protection order. So, one, no, this was
like hours before the protection order um on my YouTube channel.
Number one. Number two, I edited out cuz I went back and I edited
out the cuz there was an instance where I used her name and I
edited that out or August did. Apparently, it pops up a second
time in the video. Why not just do a meet and confer with us
and have us remove it? Why would you sit on this for two months
if it's so important for you to keep the name protected? Why
would you sit on this for two months, not communicate that at
all with us, and then why would you link the video and the timestamp
with the person's name in a public filing when you've already
demonstrated that you know how to file under seal? Like everything
about this is just a joke. I just I can't, dude. I I'm praying.
I'm praying. I'm praying.
Um I might buy a Civ Pro book and just start reading because
I want to write the summary judgement. I hope there are sanctions
for opposing council after this. I pray I pray. It's just this
is it's unhinged how stupid and insane the filings are on this.
But do the witness's names need to be published for you to be
able to serve discovery requests to them even though you might
already know who they are? Technically, theoretically, I can
try to find out otherwise. There's at least one witness person
is I have no idea who the this person is, but also nothing that
on their declaration is relevant to this case at all either.
So actually none of the declarations are relevant to the case
except for um the one person whose screen name is called out.
I don't want to say that. I don't even know what I should or
shouldn't say public terms of the name. Um although they haven't
responded to any discovery requests related to this person or
the evidence that they are purporting to have. H but yeah, it's
all just it's all super super super stupid and goofy. But is
there a chance that they're just trying to keep this going as
long as possible to hurt you financially as much as possible?
That is no. There is no chance of that. That is absolutely what
they're doing. Yes. The the only purpose right now is to basically
just weaponize the civil court system as much as possible to
try to cause as much damage to me reputationally, financially
as much as possible. That's their that's the only purpose of
what's happening now. That's
100%. Which is whatever. I mean, you have the legal right to
do it, I guess. But I this is why but I'm hoping as part of a
summary judgement that there are I hope that opposing council
is punished for the behavior because they've violated like several
rules at this point in terms of how they're conducting themselves.
And it seems to me that it's willful but you know I don't know
what the standards are when it comes to like sanctioning people
or what the standards are when it comes to getting people in
trouble for actually around. So who knows? It's funny how their
meet and confer was emailing Andrew like two hours before they
file and not even making any effort to see if they could resolve
it with Yeah, they did the meet and confer. They said that we
met our obligations for meet and confer. They emailed my lawyer
90 minutes before filing. And they're like, "Well, it might have
been 900 p.m. Florida time. It was 6:00 p.m. California time.
So, he actually still should have been awake." Like, "Bro, are
you 90 minutes? What?" Like, it's not my fault. Well, it's not
our fault that you're filing all this at the last minute because
you're either too busy or don't know what you're doing or you're
too lazy or you're overworked or whatever the or you're doing
it pro bono so you don't want to put any actual time towards
it. Like yeah, it's it's you know unhinged. It's crazy. Is there
an ETF for summary judgement? I don't know somebody. Where am
I probable? How long does Discovery last? Like a month or two.
So hopefully in three months I guess maybe I don't know. President
of the United States type. I'm pretty sure I feel like I read
this at one point.
Um, I thought I read somewhere that if you you can't file stuff,
arbitrary stuff, that's not a real term. You you're not allowed
to file stuff just so that a case can survive summary judgement.
That that's like an actual sanctionable or call outable thing.
I don't know if Jen or someone else in my chat, but you're not
allowed to like if you think a case is going to lose on summary
judgement, you can't just file some to go to trial that that's
like a specific thing that's called out somewhere. But I don't
know. What does sanction on opposing council mean? Like do the
lawyers lose their license? I know they lose their license, but
they should have like some kind of punishment or reprimand against
the Yes. against the opposing council, the lawyers. Yeah. Because
I think they're filing stuff and they're doing stuff that they're
not supposed to. I don't even think for instance throwing on
witnesses like after a complaint has been filed that aren't even
part of the original complaint. like plaintiffs stated that a
supporter reached out to her and said that the supporter's sister
had received um the video that is the um that is the
um subject of the complaint uh like 4 months ago. That's what
she claimed to the complaint. That person never materialized.
Okay. Without that person, the complaint is uh is dismissed because
it's the law wasn't active when she was alleging the original
video was transmitted. So, they threw that in there. So that
makes it survive a motion to dismiss, right? Because now there's
a dispute of fact. But now that the now that we've we're in discovery,
we've been through discovery for a bit. That person never materialized.
Okay. So that person just wasn't real. I guess you just put that
in your complaint and you didn't have an affidavit or a decorant
or anything. You didn't have nothing. So I don't know if that
person was even real. And now we've thrown on another random
person. But why? Where did this person come from? Like you didn't
get that from me. That wasn't part of my discovery. I didn't
have that. So did you have this person all along and you just
didn't file it with your original complaint? I'm pretty sure
you were supposed to amend the complaint to have her part in
there. I don't think you can just keep throwing people on. You're
not allowed to do that. You can't just keep adding random witnesses
and unless I believe if it comes up as part of discovery, I think
you're allowed there's a process by which you can file motions
or whatever to do that. But um yeah, I don't know. It's like
I said, it's all wacky. How often do you communicate with the
law firm in this case? Um probably every other day or something.
Generally, if a motion is filed, they usually will forward it
to me and they'll say like, "Hey, like can you give me notes
on this or whatever?" because I have to give them all the information
that I have about a thing that they might file and then they
make official filings from there basically.
And at the end, wait, hold on. I'm so sorry. Stop, Jen. I see
you typing nonsense in my YouTube chat. Not nonsense. I'm so
sorry. Proving it's difficult. Destiny has really, really good
lawyers though, and it seems she really doesn't in federal court
before discoveries. Okay, I'm this meme rumor right now. Okay,
because people are doing this thing where it's like, oh, he's
got the good lawyers and she doesn't. That is true. I do have
a really good law firm. Um, however, her mistakes right now or
the mistakes from opposing council are not because they're like
bad lawyers and that like they just don't have the resources
or whatever to go. They're they're failing like basic civil procedure
stuff. Like they're they're failing on the basics and they're
acting incredibly vindictive in terms of at least in my opinion
in terms of how they're persecuting this case. They're being
incredibly vindictive, incredibly unprofessional and they're
missing basic civ cro rules. That's not like, oh, it was just
a they just got outmaneuvered in some advanced strategy by like
a crazy, you know, powerful law firm. It was just it's the honest
to god answers. They just don't have a case and they know that
and they're just flailing. But and someone comes up, you got
any change? And Jesus is like, "Sorry, mate. You know, I haven't
I haven't got any." Hunter said she got a really good law firm.
Yeah. Because everybody everybody when they first covered the
case, I was completely doomed and destroyed and dead and there
was no way I'd ever survived. And everybody said, "Oh my god,
it's an amazing law firm." because they went on the website and
they saw that they did like 50 different areas of law and then
they were like, "Oh my god, they even brought in another lawyer
from out of district. Oh, he's going to get destroyed." And then
slowly the cope has changed to, "Oh, okay. Well, he just got
a good law firm." Or, "Oh, okay. Well, he's intimidating all
the witnesses somehow." or oh then so the cope has like changed
like over and over and over and over and over again to where
um not to bring up the my Voldemorts but I think Kelly was in
uh one of her side discords that they keep saying they're not
making which is really funny because they keep making them and
them talking about like we've got to get rid of the spies or
whatever which is funny to read cuz I'm everywhere again. Um
but now it's like oh I don't even care what happens as a result
of the case like at least his reputation got harmed. I actually
don't care about the outcome at all. It doesn't even matter anymore.
Haha. And I was like, "Okay, good one, Nice." They You guys have
been filing back and forth. Has the court said anything about
the disagreements between you two? No, not yet. Although I think
we're finally hopefully starting to come up on where judge is
going to have to respond to some stuff. Did your theory of mind
and the nature of people further develop due to the absurdity
of a court case? Um, a little bit, but it's stuff that I mainly
learned already over 2024. I think again, a lot of this is just
from stuff that happened in 2022, 2023.
Now, I don't know if you can say, but what have your lawyers
said about the other council's actions? Have they talked about
it? Um, I'd like to be a little careful about what I say about
my conversations with my lawyers because technically that's like
privileged, meaning the opposing council can't touch it unless
I bring it up publicly. Um, but like I'll say like in a very
general sense, yeah, like I'm I'm asking I'm also checking with
friends and stuff too because like I said, there's five people
think about me. I'm always like super nervous about like am I
way in over my not in over my head but like am I am I way too
confident in this particular area or like am I missing something
really obvious but it the overwhelming majority of everybody
that I've spoken to seems to be like yeah opposing council is
being incredibly like crazy on this so and that seems to be the
case but who knows we'll seeing the judge talk about the TTRO
was like a provided me a great deal of relief because I was worried
for that TR hearing where I was like, "Oh god, maybe I'm like
maybe there is actually something I'm super misunderstanding
about all of this and that TR is going to get granted and I'm
like just totally not understanding something." But seeing her
rig them over the coals I think was like okay. All right, not
super crazy. Odds on you getting any of your costs back? Um,
I have no idea. We'll see. We'll see. That's impossible to predict.
I think they would have to really really really really up for
that. Will you read their response to your thing? The last thing
it's just more of the same. It's just more of the same like slop
lawyer slop comes now plaintiff Jane Doe in binding through undersigned
counsel and files her right reply to defend teams opposition
motion to file declarations under sale plaintiff's motion for
leave to file declarations under seal seeks to have the unredacted
declarations of three witnesses filed under seal um in order
to protect their identities pursuant to local rule 54b1 plaintiff
attached to the redacted versions of the three declarations to
her simultaneously filed reply to the opposition motion The portions
declarations that are redacted are only those that would serve
to identify the witnesses. The substantive content is not redacted.
Defendant Bonell opposes the motion on three reported grounds.
One, plaintiff's failure to meet and confer. They gave us 90
minutes. Number one. Number two, plaintiff's refusal to identify
the names of the declarance. They won't identify them to us.
Not allowed to do that. And three, the rule upon which plaintiff
relies is not applicable. For the reasons set forth below, defendant's
arguments are unavailing. Furthermore, it bears nothing or it
bears noting the defendant fails to address the merits of the
motion and the critical need to have the identity of these declarants
protected. Okay. Meeting confer plaintiff did not fail to meet
and confer. Plaintiff made efforts to meet and confer but was
unable to obtain defendants's position prior to the deadline
for filing. Plaintiff then continued with her efforts to confer
with defendant and resolve the issues raised. But plaintiff's
efforts proved fruitless. So remember it was 90 minute. They
give they gave my lawyer 90 minutes to respond to this motion
on like a Friday night. Okay. Before they filed, I think I don't
I don't know if it was a Friday night, but it was like Yeah,
it was at night. It was like, okay.
Um, plaintiff then
contin plaintiff complied with both the letter and spirit of
local rules 7182. Moreover, it is apparent that defendants's
opposition from defendants's opposition that he was completely
unwilling to reach any reasonable resolution of the issue. The
only reasonable resolution, I guess, is for them to have secret
witnesses that come forth that are fully redacted that we never
get to know who they are, I
Okay. Thus, defendants's first ground for denying leave to file
under seal is without basis in law of fact. Okay. Plaintiff's
refusal to identify the names. Defendant's second purported ground
for denying the motion is also without merit. Pliff's refusal
to identify the names of the declarance prior to the court's
ruling on the motion is not a reason to deny the motion. Rather,
it is merely a nonsensical demand by defendant. The precise purpose
of the motion is to protect the identities of the declarance.
Wrong. This is not true. I don't know why they can write this.
The purpose of the motion to file under seal is to protect the
identities of the declarance from the public. Filing under seal
means that you protect it from the public, not from the defense.
I don't know why they keep saying things in their motions that
are wrong. This is just not true. These declarations contain
highly sensitive private and confidential information regarding
the non-consensual distribution of explicit materials and related
communications involving the witnesses, plaintiff and other individuals,
not of the witnesses that the witnesses are not parties to the
case in so far as they are um in so far as they're plaintiffs.
These are just supposed to be in support of the
complaint. I don't know why you would bring up anything related
to anything of them in any of their declarations. It seems improper.
Seems like you're exposing them to more unwanted harassment or
risk or whatever than they even should be. It has nothing to
do with the complaint. Defendant's insistence that he be prematurely
provided with the names of the declarance prior to the court's
ruling on the motion would defeat the very purpose of the motion.
Again, the purpose of filing under seal is not to keep the names
hidden from opposition. The purpose of filing under seal is to
keep the names out of the public. I don't know why they keep
saying this. I don't understand. They just don't. This is just
crazy. Local rule 54B1 is the only applicable rule. If you read
local rules of civil procedure for the state of Florida, nothing
here has anything to do with keeping names hidden from the defense.
In a case that is not otherwise sealed in its entirety as permitted
or required by federal law, file and serve electronically via
CMCF, a motion to file under seal that sets forth the factual
and legal basis for departing from the policy. So you can have
an entire case filed under seal if you file it initially like
that, but this one is not like that. Um, we had to take a look.
Okay. The proposed sealed material shall not be filed unless
the court grants the motion to file under seal. The motion to
file under seal shall specify the proposed duration of the requested
sealing. The motion to file this is just how to file something
under seal. That's all this rule is for. It has nothing to do
filing something under seal does not mean that you hiding it.
You don't hide it from the defense. That's not how this works.
I don't know why they cite this. There's nothing in the rules
of civil procedure that allow you to hide things from the defense.
That's not There's no local civil procedure rule for Florida.
There is no federal civil procedure rule that I'm aware of. Somebody
can point out to me they haven't cited it. Local rule 54B1 provides
some relevant part. If prior to the issuance of a ruling on the
motion to fall under seal, the moving party elects or is required
to publicly file a pleading, motion, memorandum, or other document
that attaches or reveals the content of the proposed sealed material,
then the moving party must redact from the public filing all
content that is the subject of the motion to file under seal.
Now, for this, I don't know if you're supposed to redact the
entire declaration or just the stuff that you want hidden. I
feel like you're supposed to redact all of it. Meaning, I don't
think that they were allowed to f because usually I believe when
you file something under seal, the entire declaration, the entire
thing is under seal. So, I don't know if they were even allowed.
I don't I don't know the answer to this and I don't have any
law school friends who know the answer to this. Um, I didn't
ask my lawyer. I should have. I don't know if you're allowed
to just redact a couple parts of it and file the rest. This the
re the way that I read this is you shouldn't file anything or
the whole thing should be redacted because this is saying um
if prior to the issuance of a ruling on the motion to file under
seal. So we don't have a ruling from the court yet. The moving
party the party filing the motion elects or is required to publicly
file a pleading motion memorandum or other document that attaches
or reveals the content of the proposed sealed material. So the
declaration that they're filing that they've redacted something
that they want to file under seal. U then the moving party must
redact from the public filing all content that is the subject
of the motion to file under seal. So I feel like the entire thing
shouldn't have been filed publicly like that without the whole
thing being redacted. That would be that's how I read this. I
could be reading it incorrectly though. I don't know. I don't
have any other examples to draw from here and they don't site
any cases that I can see. So
um thus the rule specifically allows the filer to publicly file
a redacted version of the document if feasible and simultaneously
submit a motion file under sealed the unredacted version.
Okay. I don't know if that is the case. If this says that because
it says you have to redact all content that is the subject of
the motion, but I don't know. This is like I I I don't know.
I'm not super confident in my reading there because I just don't
know. But also again, this has nothing to do with hiding it from
us. This has nothing to do with hiding it from us. The only thing
I can think of is if there is no enforcement mechanism, if you
were to leak the names before motion to seal is granted, after
it's granted, then you'd be legally bound not to disclose. Well,
no. I wouldn't I can't leak stuff that when they've said that
they are proposing to file something under seal. If they make
that known to us and they say that we're going to try to file
a seal for this and I leak the names beforehand, I would be in
trouble for that. I'm pretty sure that they could file um to
to get remedies from the court if I were to engage in that behavior.
Defendants reliance on local rule 54 F1A is misplaced. This rule
is not applicable to redactive filings accompanied by sealing
motion. The only applicable rule in this instance is 53B1 which
does not require disclosure part of the court's ruling on motion.
Thus, defendants the critical need to protect the identities
of the witnesses. Defendant's opposition completely ignores the
substantive basis for the motion. One, good cause for sealing
the identities is established since the declarations contain
sensitive and private intimate
details. Why? One, those details aren't even relevant to the
cases. So, I don't know why you even including those, which is
bizarre. Okay. Um, number one. Number two, public disclosure
of the identities of these witnesses would expose the witnesses
to harassment, embarrassment, possible harm, and retaliation.
Then why did you include one of their screen names? Number one.
And number two, we're not talking about public disclosure. We're
talking about private disclosure to me. I'm I'm I'm allowed to
know who's accusing me or who's claiming to be a witness on things
as set forth in exhibit three to the defendant's opposition.
Defendant has publicly threatened physical harmed individuals
that have spoken out against him and in support of plaintiff
partisan. I if I whatever I'd show up at their house and do it,
I do want someone to kill Lav Mr. Orman. All those people can
go die. None of these people are parties to this case. You can
also cite a bunch of crazy I've said about Trump or the firefighter,
whatever else. These people have nothing to do with this case.
I don't know if we're just playing random quotations from stream
to throw into our court motions, but these are they're not relevant
parties here. Defendant regularly streams on his YouTube channel
the details of his case, including confidential details from
meet and convers. None of I haven't revealed anything confidential,
and I'm allowed to go over the public filings. This is a public
case. You wanted to file this publicly, and now I can read the
public filings. I have every right to do that. There's a reason
why these these are public filings. It's a public court case.
I haven't revealed anything that I'm not supposed to under seal.
I haven't revealed anything that has been redacted. After the
reply, emotions were filed. He streamed about the filings, showing
them on his screen. Yeah, they're public
filings. Destiny. Yeah. And it establishes a pattern of behavior.
No, it doesn't. That's not character evidence that's allowed
in court. You can't just show random things just because I might
be willing to talk. I talk about a ton of people or make threats
or whatever. Say there's a bunch of people that should die. That
doesn't mean that I would necessarily do that to somebody who's
the subject of a court case. This is why this this is exactly
why this type of character evidence isn't allowed in court. You
can't just have um you can't just say like, "Oh, well, he said
like these unhinged things to his siblings before, so I think
that's why he would me if he was like, "No, what
the?" After the reply and the motion were filed, he streamed
about the filings, showing them on his screen, reading excerpts
aloud, and providing vitriolic and defamatory commentary. I'm
allowed to talk about their public filings. I agree that they
aren't right, but they're trying to do that. Oh, yeah. Of course.
Yeah, they're trying to. Yeah, this video has been viewed 115,83
times to date. In it, defendant accuses plaintiff of extorting
and blackmailing him. Um, of insane lies, of a total lie. Defendant
accu Yes, it's my I'm allowed to have an opinion about my court
case. No. Defendant accuses witness Abby MC. Nice. Thanks for
keeping her identity redacted, by the way. Thanks for keeping
all of that uh private and under seal as you continue to publish
witnesses names that you say that I'm harassing and intimidating.
I don't know why you would continue to publish their screen names
publicly, but okay. Of lying and perjury. He refers to the undersigned
council as disgusting. Oh, that's them. Nice. I am. Yes. Include
this at your next I look forward to being in your next court
filing. That's right. I think you are. Um and repeatedly accuses
the undersigned council of grabbing random people to purchase
themselves. I do. I'll show me your next filing. I'm here. Thumbs
up. Link me. Put a screenshot. Apparently, all of this commentary
is approved by defendants council. I pass everything that I publish
by my lawyers first. Uh I don't talk to my lawyers about every
single thing I say on stream. Um the thing that I conferred with
them the most on was on my um the writing the mini fest or whatever
the I did to see what is okay or what's not okay. And then I've
like asked them generally like I'm allowed to talk about my public
filings on stream or whatever, right? Um it's not like I write
down every single statement that I say and then I give it to
my lawyers and I was like can I call the opposing council disgusting?
And my lawyers are like yes call them disgusting. Um, but this
the the opposition council here is desperate to attack my law
firm as well. They're desperate to attack my my representation
as well. Furthermore, despite the protective order entered by
this court to protect plaintiff Jane Doe's identity, defendant
publicly disclosed plaintiff Jane Doe's legal name on his social
media platform. So, one, this was the this was before the um
seal or whatever on identity was approved by the court. Um, two,
uh, once they had once the court granted that motion, I removed
her name from the video. Three, apparently I say, uh, her first
name a second time in this video. I was unaware of that. But
if the plaintiff's name is so concerning to you, why would you
not email us and say, "Hey, your client
um, said the person's name before that motion was they said the
person name this YouTube video. Can you edit that out, please?
because we want to be protective of our client's name. Why wouldn't
you make us aware of that? Why would you hold on to this for
2 months and then publish it publicly in a filing instead of
publishing it or instead of filing it under seal and not confer
with us at all to remove it? Do you not care at all about the
name being private? Is it all just for show? Like it's just wild.
The behavior is wild here. This video has been viewed over 130,000
times. In the same video, defendant postplaintiff's private messages
to him about her emotional distress and thoughts due to his nonsensual
sharing of the video and then mocks and ridicules her. She already
made a public substack about me. Yes, plaintiff already made
a super public substack about me. Other people have already filed
videos about this or not filed, I'm sorry, public videos about
this. Of course, I'm going to talk about it. You've already publicly
called me out. No sh I'm going to respond
publicly. He then tells his 183,000 subscribers lowballing me,
please. That plant emotional stress tribe solely for the purpose
of extorting him. This none of this has any I'm sorry, but none
of this has anything to do with you seeking any sort of protective
order whatsoever. Again, I'm allowed to have opinions on my case.
And even if your protective order is granted, I can still have
all of these opinions about my case and I can still say them
publicly. Unless you're trying to seek a gag order or you're
trying to seek some incredibly extensive I think you might be
able to get a really extensive protective order um that prohibits
me from talking about it all publicly. Unless you're going after
that, then you I talk about and say whatever the I want.
Um, it is readily apparent that the three declarants, Abby, MC,
and witnesses A and B, need the court to steal their identities
in order to protect them from public intimidation, retaliation,
and psychological harm relentlessly perpetrated by defendant.
This doesn't make sense. If you think that I'm going to harass
them, then you're not looking to you're not looking to file these
under seal. You're looking to keep these hidden from me, which
you're not allowed to do. number one. And number two, your um
your a motion to file to seal something doesn't keep it private
for me. That's not even what this does. You're not It's not even
Further relief may be required to give defendants continued efforts
um I'm sorry. Further relief may be required given defendants
continued efforts to dox and intimidate both the plaintiff and
the witnesses in this matter. Who what who I what by serving
subpoenas or by serving discovery requests? I have not published
any information about any of these people publicly that are the
subject matter of the complaint or that are witnesses or that
are attached to the complaint. I don't even know what the [__]
this means or refers to. Who? What? But anyway, yeah, it's all
of this is like this is literally lawyer slop is what we've got
here. What is the correct response that a lawyer should do if
they are worried about them being harassed? I mean, I guess it
depends on the level of harassment you're worried about. Like,
if you think somebody's gonna show up and kill you, then you
should like call the cops or something. In my personal opinion,
maybe I'm a little sociopathic, I guess. I don't know. In my
personal opinion, you want the plaintiff to harass you. That's
like a dream scenario because if your case actually gets to trial,
then now you're looking at big secondary damages. So, the stat
the statutory cap on damages the plaintiff can get from me, assuming
it goes to trial, assuming she wins, and assuming she's given
the max compensatory award
$150,000. But for tort, the jury could levy secondary damages
onto you. And if the jury is watching the trial, and if during
the trial, they say, "Hey, um, uh, the defense literally tried
to dox me publicly. He was harassing me publicly. He posted my
information. He was contacting my friends and family. He was
doing all these horrible things." A jury might look at that and
go, you know what,
this this guy was around and you know what, we're going to award
plaintiff more on this case. We think plaintiff is entitled to
more damages here because she suffered a great deal of emotional
harm and everything else that was furthered um as a result of
this case. So, in those cases, I would imagine it would benefit
you when it comes to getting secondary damages awarded to you.
But
anyway, isn't that what they were trying to set up? They were
claiming you're harassing them, but they return I I don't know
what I don't know. I I don't I still don't think the complaint
will survive summary judgement, but who knows? We'll see. Read
the court's local rules to show everyone why you think that they
cannot keep the identities away from you, but only the public.
Here's link to the district they site. Yeah, we already I went
through some of them on stream or I think I read the paragraph
that they're citing. Nothing. I I control yesterday. I control
opposing. Um I control F available. I looked through all of this.
I can't find anything in here. Um, the only local rule that I
found, but again, the joke in law school is that civil procedure
is like the hardest class because there are so many different
rules. Um, and I' I've heard people say that like you don't even
really learn CIP Pro until you actually start practicing CI civil
procedure and then you like you learn the rules as you do it
because there's just so many. Um, so like I mean I'm being honest,
there could be something that I'm just completely missing. Um,
but when I went through the only thing that I could find that
was remotely relevant to anything, but I also feel like I want
to be careful when I say this because I don't like the word common
sense
but hold on, I'm looking at the email I sent last night. When
I went through this and I have I've not read all the local rules
for super in Florida. Okay, assuming that's what these are all
for. Um 7 oh
I if new evidence or witnesses are discovered after the pre-trial
conference the party desiring their use shall immediately furnish
complete details thereof and the reason for late discovery to
the court and to opposing council use may be allowed by the court
in furtherance of the ends of justice. This is for like newly
discovered evidence or witnesses. I don't know if that would
apply to the new witness that they threw on to this, but I mean
um I don't know if there's other more general rules, but like
like I mean I know as a matter of common sense, I hate to say
that, but I know this is true. I'll give all my money away if
it's not. You in in the United States of America, you have a
right to confront your accuser and the the people have to make
known to you like who they are and who witnesses are. You can't
those can't be anonymous. But it's like it's common sense, right?
Like imagine I say, "Oh,
um, I know that you murder John." It's like, "How do you know
that?" Uh, because witness A, B, C, and D all said that you did
it. They said they saw you do it. And it's like, what? Well,
who are they? I'm not going to tell you. You might go kill them,
too. Oh, well me, I guess. Like, I don't
know. Do you think the Jane do thing will be a problem? What
do you mean a problem? I mean, reputationally, obviously, it's
already been a problem, but I mean, I don't anticipate, like
I said, I don't anticipate this surviving the summary judgement
still.